uh as someone who's been very vocal
about being a batman fan for pretty much
your whole life can you describe the
feeling of putting on the bat suit for
the first time was it empowering or
emotional or anything
um yeah i mean i had from getting cast
to putting it on the first time there
was that's probably 10 months
and like and so you've gone through the
whole thing with like sort of fan
reaction and then your your own reaction
and the fan reaction i've been thinking
and then trying to prepare for it and
then reading the most
untold number of graphic novels
and uh
when you finally get to put on the suit
it just suddenly it it kind of
it makes it real but it's suddenly you
suddenly think you can do something
totally different with the character
because there's no
it's weird that you put it on the first
you put it on the first time you and
it's so well designed it fits so
perfectly and you can move in it so well
and you just look in the mirror and
you're like oh [ __ ]
uh but yeah it's incredibly powerful and
you can really feel you know that's
there's so much history that's imbued
into the into the suit and the kind of
iconography of it and um
and you can really feel it when you put
it on boy on screen the role of catwoman
has been played by some legendary
actresses over years from earth to kid
to michelle pfeiffer how does it feel to
take on the mantle of such a powerful
female character
it's scary it's scary and exciting you
know i think you know because she's so
beloved by so many people and all of the
different versions of her have been so
wonderful and i think for me the the key
was really trying to trust that matt you
know chose me for a reason that i could
really so i could really let go and be
free and and try and you know
make make her my own which is what we
love so much about the other versions
those women they completely owned the
character and so that's what i i tried
to do this is a pretty dark unique take
on the character of the rittler you know
showing a disturbing side of society and
the troubled individuals feel slighted
by the status quo
how did you as an actor get into the
headspace and how do you then get out of
it is it something that like stuck with
you after filming
um
i think making the work as personal as
possible whether that means for me or
just on the character's behalf rather
than about the bigger picture it's
actually about the two sides of trauma
batman's born of trauma and so
in this film maybe is the riddler and
that is kind of the seed from which
everything else grew uh it was not
always easy to uh
uh come down from work um
uh
but that's uh
sometimes the accrual of energy when
you're shooting an intense sequence is
is is your your friend even though it
doesn't always feel like it and and uh
you know now i look back on this with
with really fond memories but there was
a couple tough days
so this performance as the penguin was
truly something like spectacular so
nuance and it was just very interesting
and
did you work out the characters like
mannerisms accent with matt and the crew
or like how did you bring the specific
version to the of the penguin to life
i i've worked with thanks man i've
worked over the last eight or ten years
with an extraordinary dialect coach
named jessica drake
so i felt like by the time i saw
the makeup i had a foundation
but then when i saw mike mourinho's
makeup i just it just took the character
and the possibility of the character to
a whole nother level for me and then the
first time i i got the makeup put on was
just i felt like i was off to the races
man i felt like just yeah it was just so
much fun to explore the manner the
mannerisms and the behaviors came more
from seeing mike mourinho's work because
i could see from that visage there was a
lot of violence and there was it was
painful and was also kind of there was a
kind of a as violence as the face looked
there was a kind of a sense of sorrow
there as well a little bit that that
made it interesting for me so yeah i had
a lot of people that i leaned into for
it you know
you